make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and
welcome back to comics explain where i
make you an expert on comic books in 30
minutes or less and in this video
i'm gonna make you an expert on sam
wilson but only sam wilson
as he was captain america honestly
because at the moment nobody really
cares about sam wilson when he was
falcon
i say that because in at the end of the
episode six which is coming out this
week it's actually tuesday that i'm
recording this i'm assuming sam wilson
is gonna become captain america and
nobody cares about sam wilson when he's
falcon right nobody's gonna be googling
sam wilson as falcon they're gonna be
googling sam wilson captain america
that's what they're looking for and so
that's what we're gonna cover here so
one of the things to understand is that
sam wilson becoming captain america as
far as rick remember the guy who did
this he thought it was just an
inevitable result of what
basically needed to be something that
changed the reality of this is there was
an interview he did with entertainment
weekly where he was asked why it was
that he changed
captain america from steve rogers to sam
wilson and he felt that it was necessary
because for a long time he was it was
always steve rogers and
most marvel superheroes most mainstream
superheroes of marvel were white guys
and so what he wanted to do was turn
captain america into a minority
character basically turned sam wilson
into captain america so people who were
not white people could see themselves
represented in comics and hold prominent
positions now as you might expect this
created a bunch of backlash
and the backlash to sam wilson becoming
captain america really only ever came
from three directions
the first is people who were just
legitimately racist the second is people
and this is probably one of the more
interesting aspects
people who didn't agree with the idea
placing existing characters with
minority characters they considered it
tokenism and a lot of people kind of
came across with that argument and
saying
why not just give them their own series
and then focus on that right build the
character up in that way
now people who come from that
perspective are people who usually don't
read comics
or didn't know anything about sam wilson
because in 1983 and 1984 marvel tried
that with a limited series as a test bed
to see whether or not a solo series
could work and it didn't nobody really
bought the limited series and so a solo
series never came to fruition more
recently marvel tried that after sam
wilson was captain america when he went
back to being falcon and it still didn't
do very well right i mean it only ran
for about eight issues and it was
cancelled due to low sales despite the
fact that the story was exceedingly good
and so the reality was
people don't care about sam wilson as
falcon when it's just sam wilson by
himself right they care about sam wilson
when he's either captain america or
playing alongside captain america the
the third aspect in the third direction
people were coming from is that they
simply just didn't want things to change
right that things were a certain way
steve rogers was captain america is what
they were used to and they just wanted
it to stay that way
in terms of you know any kind of ratio
or percentages like whether you know
it's like a 70
and 2010 split between like racists and
then people who didn't want change
versus people who were you know wanted
sam wilson to have stories that were
beefed up i don't know like i don't
really know what that ratio was and
honestly i don't really care what it is
the reality is that was just kind of the
three directions with regards to a lot
of
a lot of the backlash that were coming
from this now as it was the stories with
sam wilson as captain america were
fantastic at least i thought they were
and the way that rick remember did this
is he immediately went into this idea
of sam wilson being being viewed by
america as a false captain america right
that they looked at that and they said
no steve rogers is captain america we
don't know who this guy is but we're
going to cast him off the lead up to
that was one of the best things to come
out of captain america storytelling what
rick remember ended up doing was kicking
all this off with a story called
castaway and dimension z
and this was basically a story where
steve rogers was whisked away to a
dimension that belonged to arnhem zola
now ultimately he was able to escape
but shortly after that he ended up in a
conflict with a guy by the name of the
iron nail who basically stripped steve
rogers of his super soldier serum and
that resulted in steve rogers aging up
and becoming an old man and so in
response to that steve rogers ended up
getting into a bit of a skirmish and
then realized he didn't quite have the
kind of wherewithal that he used to have
right he couldn't fight in the same
capacity that he did and so this led to
him
giving sam wilson the shield because he
and sam wilson have been have been you
know partners for quite
some time and so the reality was it was
the most natural transition
we did see marvel try bucky barnes as
captain america and it was cool for what
it was but ultimately you know steve
rogers ended up coming back and that was
one of the big things and i think a lot
of people who were upset about sam
wilson being captain america seem to
kind of overlook and it's one of the
reasons why it's really important to
understand the nature of comics if
you're gonna start making arguments like
that
because in comics nothing stays changed
forever in the end
everything basically ends up going back
to the status quo the only exception to
that is that uncle ben's never been
never been brought back
in terms of being of truly returning and
marvel comics he's basically still dead
you've seen versions of him come back
from the spider-man mythos but steve
rogers at one point was nomad and then
went back to being captain america we
saw that steve rogers lost the captain
america manchester in the 80s due to the
uh commission on superhuman activities
which led to john walker becoming
captain america and then steve rogers
went back to being captain america again
steve rogers died in the aftermath of
civil war which led to bucky barnes
becoming
captain america and then steve rogers
came back and was captain america again
right so as long as you read comics for
any real measure of time one of the most
important things you learn
is that nothing stays changed forever
and it's all it all just circles back to
the status quo right it's just the way
those things always work and so leading
into
or or really kind of coming up on
jonathan hickman's secret wars event
just prior to that you got a six issue
series and it's really more of just a
singular story arc and you can even call
it a mini series if you wanted to that
was called all new captain america
written by rick remender and it was
really reminders chance to kind of craft
sam wilson as captain america and the
way that he imagined him being
before the events of secret war started
and the aftermath essentially picked up
and so one of the most important things
to come out of remember's run here was
something that basically dealt with
removing or
changing the snap wilson concept now the
way this worked is that originally sam
wilson
was a guy who had basically struggled
with the death of his parents in you
know by violent means and he ultimately
ended up volunteering and becoming a
social worker but was tricked into
traveling to an island called exile by
the red skull now supposedly the red
skull would use a cosmic cube to give
sam wilson the power to communicate with
birds but the important thing here
is that uh sam wilson allied himself
with steve rogers in order to stop the
red skull and his henchmen which led to
sam wilson becoming a sidekick to steve
rogers or a partner to steve rogers
however in captain america 186 there was
a story
written by steve englehart which
basically revealed this idea that sam
wilson's true persona the actual sam
wilson was a guy named snap wilson who
was essentially like a thug or some kind
of a henchman who was actually getting
into drug running but when he was
brought over to the island of exile that
the red skull had used a cosmic cube to
change the past
of of snap wilson and to basically give
him the name sam wilson and then to give
him the story of being like a charitable
volunteer worker so that sam wilson
could basically partner with captain
america and then essentially betray
captain america at red skull's wishes
somewhere along the line after
gathering a whole bunch of information
that could be used against steve rogers
uh the problem with this was that steve
englehart left the captain america
series before he could actually explain
why this was done now jmd matthias did
try to fix this in captain america 276
through 278
but ultimately no real work was done it
just kind of stayed there and so for a
long long time
there was this kind of belief among
comic book fans and even a little bit of
vitriol from minority comic book fans
that marvel had in effect
changed the history of sam wilson in
order to make him a black stereotype as
opposed to
a guy who was a charitable volunteer and
social worker who eventually became
captain america's sidekick but the idea
of rick remender was to go back and it
basically just
completely and totally changed that and
so what he did is he kind of reversed
things
and so he effectively told the story or
kind of had this revelation by way of
the red skull's daughter
that sam wilson is actually sam wilson
he really is a charitable volunteer
worker and social worker the red skull
using the cosmic cube to manipulate his
past that was done for the purpose
of creating snap wilson and so in effect
the red skull created a black stereotype
for sam wilson and then was ultimately
just kind of cast aside and removed
it was about the best you could do
outside of just rebooting the character
in its entirety uh but that's really the
the big significant moment there the
kind of underlying themes in terms of
what was going on with this character in
a lot of ways just dealt with sam wilson
facing off against hydra which depending
on who you talk to
may or may not be a good thing i thought
it was okay but hydra was largely a
steve rogers enemy and i felt it would
have been a little more appropriate to
create a personal enemy or at least a
personal uh villainous group for sam
wilson to face off against
instead of just retreading the old
enemies of steve rogers but regardless
of how you slice it in the aftermath of
jonathan hickman's secret wars in 2015
you ended up getting nick spencer who
took over the captain america line of
stories
and to say that nick spencer's run was
divisive is an
understatement i personally loved it i
thought nick spencer's run on captain
america was better than ed brubaker's
run it's probably the single greatest
captain america run that i'd ever read
but there were a lot of people out there
who felt otherwise in the most extreme
who look at nick spencer's captain
america run and see it as the worst one
of all time there were of course those
and you probably remember some
highlights people who were
really pissed off because captain
america became a hydra agent a lot of
that was because
people who didn't read comics and didn't
actually know what was going on
were mad because captain america
suddenly became a hydra agent if you
read the story then you basically got
this realization
that captain america's past had been
changed by the red skull using a cosmic
cube right so that's how captain america
ended up becoming a hydra agent but the
important thing
here is that you basically had the whole
run of sam wilson
as captain america uh really kind of
ending in a way where he got his own
he had his own captain america sam
wilson solo series but basically
walking away from the role of captain
america in its entirety now the reality
is that this was a multi-staged
kind of series of events that led to sam
wilson leaving the mantle in the first
place the first of these really came
by way of word reaching his ears due to
some information that was essentially
given to him by rick jones operating
under the name of whisper
that shield was in the process of
recreating a cosmic cube which he just
didn't really agree with one because
following the events of civil war
the idea of of shield as far as sam
wilson saw and under the leadership of
maria hill had largely been tainted
because maria hill was just so gung-ho
about rounding up superheroes and
forcing them to
uh to register under you know the under
government supervision in terms of how
they acted and conducted themselves the
other part of this is that sam wilson
despite his respect for steve rogers
largely saw captain america as a hero
who just
didn't really have his ear to the ground
he wasn't really a champion of the
common man he was just kind of a
protector of the world now it doesn't
mean that steve rogers would just let an
old lady get mugged on the street but
what it did mean is that as a member of
the avengers and while he had his own
stories he was largely focused on the
bigger picture and so sam wilson
essentially between the information he
learned about shield and his belief that
captain america needed to be rooted more
in terms of
of operating on the ground level walked
away from the government in its entirety
and so following this it went into
what was probably the last straw for sam
wilson and it was really cool the way
that it was done
right so what you had here was sam
wilson basically coming across joaquin
torres who ended up becoming his own
falcon
and then the events of pleasant hill
also known as avengers standoff now the
idea of avengers standoff and pleasant
hill was basically this notion that
shield had kind of rounded up all these
different super villains and then thrown
them into a little town
and then used a cosmic cube to more or
less imprison them ultimately sam wilson
alongside the avengers ended up freeing
all these individuals who which also
included captain america but the red
skull ended up using the cosmic cube who
was kind of transformed into a little
girl to essentially rewrite steve rogers
past and make him a hydra agent and so
with this going forward you ended up
seeing kind of sam wilson going about
and doing his normal thing all the while
unaware that steve rogers as a hydra
agent now was kind of planning and
plotting and scheming against the
superhero community and he ended up
coming across a character by the name of
rage now rage was a guy who
who operated out of brooklyn and
actually ended up coming into conflict
with what was called the americorps now
the americorps was a concept put forward
by uh paul
keane and uh and harry houser and
ultimately the idea here was to kind of
have an autonomous police force
that could uh really accompany existing
police and sort of enhance
to a degree but ultimately the americops
just ended up becoming individuals who
were cracking down on minorities and so
this led to
sam wilson uh kind of going in and
initially confronting rage and then
ultimately siding against the americops
this led to harry houser and paul keane
bringing in u.s agent john walker in an
effort to send him to grab
sam wilson and take the shield away
which led to steve rogers intervening
when jim
when uh when john walker said no and
steve rogers with nobody knowing he was
a hydra agent
considered it a personal favor for john
walker to go and apprehend sam wilson
and so ultimately with the two of them
kind of getting into a bit of a skirmish
in the end sam wilson was allowed to
keep the shield and just kind of went
forward from there
and so ultimately with rage kind of
being busted or at least you know being
accused of robbing a bodega
uh because of the fact that the entire
situation seemed so exceedingly unfair
sam wilson just walked away he just
abandoned the role between the
the accusations of the american people
that he was not fit to be captain
america because he wasn't steve rogers
the various racial issues he'd run into
and just seemingly this all around kind
of coming from every direction hostile
uh position he abandoned the role in its
entirety what this did is it allowed him
to kind of be removed from the picture
and set the stage for secret empire now
now the truth about sam wilson is that
had he been active as captain america
during secret empire it wouldn't have
really made a difference
but secret empire was essentially the
story whereby captain america had
executed his plan as a hydra agent to
conquer north america and then
his intention to conquer the rest of the
world for sam wilson he largely stayed
off the radar
until what you had was a group called
the underground and the underground was
basically just the remains of the
superhero community who just hadn't
really been uh been trapped in in
various places and then you basically
had you know everybody else who was
trying to operate and
you know overcome the forces of steve
rogers as best they could sam wilson
ended up coming out of retirement to a
degree in order to help the underground
but largely didn't didn't take back or
didn't restore himself to the captain
america mantle but ultimately when the
underground was attacked by the forces
of hydra and sam wilson really just kind
of
kind of witnessing the brutality of
hydra because you know he hadn't really
seen after that point he had kind of
been out of the picture he ultimately
redone
the mantle of captain america and then
just kind of went forward from there
right
and used it as a means to try to inspire
the american people now again secret
empire was very much a political story
i loved it and the political commentary
in that was amazing for example
i believe that that steve rogers
becoming a hydra agent and the things
that he did as a hydra agent was
basically giving
the american people what they asked for
because of a real huge amount of lack of
action on behalf of the american people
in terms of doing anything to stop it
right so the apathy of
the american people led to their
circumstance and so it was a really
really cool
story it was great the way that it was
told again it's one of my absolute
favorites but ultimately the events of
secret empire came to an
end and steve rogers was kind of stuck
between a rock and a hard place right
because
on the front side the way that it ended
you kind of had the memory of steve
rogers which was restored to the to his
physical form and so you had hydra steve
or stevel as some people called him and
then you had the real steel or the
proper steve rogers ultimately the
proper steve rogers won but because of
the fact that hydra captain america or
hydra steve rogers had betrayed the
nation earning the nation's trust back
was exceedingly important and sam wilson
believed the best way to do that was to
give him the captain america shield back
and that's what he did he relinquished
the mantle of captain
america uh and returned the shield to uh
to steve rodgers and then went back to
becoming falcon so again just one of
those examples where everything that
changes
goes back to the status quo and comics
but ultimately following that
uh sam wilson got his own bit of a story
and it was cool the way that it was done
in falcon volume 2. it was a great
series of stories he ended up just kind
of going back to focusing on street
level issues street level events you
know dealing with things
across the country or really in chicago
that was basically small time
stuff but it allowed him to kind of
maintain his role on being
a relatively kind of down to earth guy
you know ultimately just in time for the
falcon and the winter soldier uh marvel
released their own solo series
honestly i haven't really read it yet um
i probably should
uh it came out in april this year i'm
sorry in april of last year so it's not
too far i mean you know
last year was well it was last year so
you know trying to maintain my sanity
was
was really just a chore in and of itself
staying current on marvel comics that
was background
but uh but nonetheless you know sam
wilson is captain america it was a
really really cool
run and it was a really cool concept the
reality is it started off with rick
remender and then just kind of went
through the entirety of nick spencer's
run and then ultimately came to an end
when ta-nehisi coates took over the the
captain america series which if you
never read uh ta-nehisi coates captain
america that one was really good too
right there was a
time there i would say with with tahasi
coach writing there was a time there for
about a year and a half
when captain america was the best thing
that nobody was reading the stories were
just fantastic i can cover them if you
guys are interested but with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here to
comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you